let's go through the wireframes for the
settings UI within the detail activity
in the overflow menu there's a settings
menu item when you tap on the settings
menu item it opens up the settings
activity if you tap on location it pops
up a dialog or you can enter in your
postal code feel free to use your
preferred method for inputting location
such as city name just verify that the
data coming back from the server is for
the location you expect note that
there's no validation on this string
input if you're trying to make this app
a production app you would want some
type of air handling here if you tap on
pick your units it opens up a dialog
where you can choose to display
temperature within the app as either
metric or imperial units this is
basically a just Celsius or Fahrenheit
and that's what the settings activity
does remember that you don't want to
make everything at setting if you're
discussing a feature with a teammate and
you can't decide on something don't
compromise by just making it a user
setting there are instances we're making
a difficult product decision now will be
better for the user because then they
don't have the burden of having to
decide what the value of the settings
should be and remember there's always an
opportunity in an app update to add the
setting later if you add it to begin
with
it's infinitely harder to take away the
setting because some users might get
angry with you if you're having trouble
deciding if something should be a
setting or not you can check out the
settings section in the Android design
guide which is linked below it contains
a workflow diagram that could help you
very few roads often lead to making
something a setting